it is an annual event that brings both
locals and tourists and it is designed
to lift you and your spirits up it's the
annual mesquite hot air balloon festival
and joining us now is christian anderson
to tell us more you're back after a year
off absolutely yeah we're happy to be
back and this is our 10th annual
mesquite hot air balloon festival we
have 35 hotter balloons coming to
mesquite and the casa blanca is going to
be the place to stay this weekend to
check out this great festival what a fun
event this is going to be you've got all
these hot air balloons and it's it's
happening all weekend long tell us a
little bit about what you have in store
for everyone absolutely yeah we have 35
great hot air balloons they're going to
be coming we're going to be doing
morning launches on friday saturday and
sunday morning and then we the best part
is the night glows and we have a friday
night night glow and a saturday night
glow so come to the casablanca resort
this weekend and just see these
beautiful balloons there tell me a
little bit more about the the launches
so the morning launches they they got to
start early i take it what time do you
expect to see those balloons off the
ground yeah safety is the number one
factor with with one of these events and
we do a safety check about 7 a.m if
mother nature and the weather is
cooperating then about 7 15 balloons
will be up in the air and once all 35 of
those dance along the
sky mesquite it's a it's a good thing to
see we talked to ted florendo and he
said you should be good on wind it's
looking real good we're excited about
that and then these night glows i never
seen anything like this before explain
that to me yeah this is a great great
event and and the balloons are tethered
to the ground so you really get up close
and personal with them uh we have a bar
out there we have a dj and we really put
on a show the balloon uh pilots love the
love the public love to show them off
and so we put some music
some cocktails some warm drinks as well
and bring the family up it's free to the
public to attend and just come to the
casablanca resort and see these
beautiful balloons now if you want to
make a weekend out of it
casablanca is a beautiful hotel do you
still have room there or if you don't
we still we still have some available
please call as soon as you can we'd love
to have you guys up um the casablanca or
the virgin river book your stay and
enjoy a great festival weekend in
mesquite now let's talk a little bit
about volunteers do you you guys need
some people to help volunteer for this
event absolutely these bloom pilots are
great but we can always use some helping
hands to help them get up in the air go
to casablanca
and go to the landing page for the
hotter balloon festival there's a link
right there you can register online to
volunteer and we'll give you all the
information you need and when and where
to be what kind of things do the
volunteers do when they go out there
yeah they really help the pilots get
their balloons prepped and ready to fly
and then once they're in the air they'll
ask them to maybe in their chase crew
they'll hop in that chase vehicle follow
the balloons when they land safely
they help them pack up those balloons
and uh and get them back to the the
launch area in the morning and one thing
you mentioned but i think it is worth
noting again is the cost a
family-friendly event for
zero dollars yeah this is this is just a
you can't beat it come up to the costa
walker resort this weekend if you go to
the morning launch or the nightclub free
to the public to attend just come and
enjoy a great weekend in mesquite and at
the casablanca resort mesquite is
beautiful the casablanca incredible
thank you so much for your time and
thank you to the casablanca resorts for
sponsoring this segment the mesquite hot
air balloon festival january 28th
through the 30th you can call
877-438-2929 or go to casablanca
casablanca resort dot com
jillian